so how was it working with God Evans on
the raid - okay one word he's a
perfectionist
he's like a hardcore perfectionist which
is a good thing and the bad thing at the
same time a good thing because you know
the results when he says it's okay then
you know okay it's really good but until
you get to that point where he says okay
it's a lot of work because he's like
really really down to the details so
like if you do a drama scene and you do
it 30 40 times that's okay but if you do
an action scene involving 100 other
fighters in the same frame in the mud in
rain with a lot of sharp objects in the
mud and you not allowed to wear any
shoes after the fifth take you're like
how much did you need to recover after
the shoot then how punishing was it okay
let's put it this way so I had one big
fighting scene which I just told you
about and we shot that scene for 10 days
straight and every day waking up at 4:30
ending at 6 p.m. and then the next day
doing it again for 10 straight days and
for those 10 days you're in adrenaline
right there pure adrenaline so you're
just okay just let's just push through
push through push through but then on
the tenth day when we finally went home
we got into a bus and then I just passed
out I slept for two days straight and
you imagine if you have wounds like you
have wet wounds and you you put medicine
on it and it's all healed but the next
day you go back into the mud so it does
not heal for 10 days yeah that's pretty
intense isn't it it's awesome no and and
the sneaky part is he's also to the
editor right and he edits on set so he
does the rough edit on set so basically
we're all like already like a little bit
annoyed we're like okay can we just you
know get it over with it was good the
last take was good was awesome and he's
like no and then finally he edits it and
he's like guys guys come over check this
out and then we see the footage and
we're like okay okay we see what you're
getting at okay fine
how many takes you need you just tell us
we will you believe you because it just
looks awesome just look I want to know
how many war wins that you have from
that shoot countless I mean can't use
all my fingers I need my toes and then
some yeah but he was worth it it was
definitely worth it it was definitely
worth it I've only seen a rough cut so
far but rough cut looks pretty good so
far so yeah I haven't seen the finished
product yet so I'm excited but yeah
we'll see how do you think audience is
gonna react to this movie because
obviously the raid 1 was so popular kind
of blew people away didn't well there's
a big difference though because I mean
the first raid movie was like just pure
action 100% you didn't get any time to
breathe and just relax here there's more
of a story to it but don't worry we're
not scaling back to action I mean
there's actually more action more of it
if you believe it or not but there's
also drama so I mean this time you
really need your time to let it sink in
and then just appreciate the movie and
cherish it and then there will be lots
of action don't worry about tell us a
little bit about your character in the
film ok my character his name is Uhtred
he is the sole son of Jakarta's most
notorious mob boss and he's very
ambitious because he thinks he needs to
prove himself to his dad and to everyone
because everyone looks kind of down on
him because he basically got everything
on a silver platter his dad he worked
his way up and he just got everything
like son someday you're gonna take over
but his dad doesn't really trust him yet
so he gives him like really like
mediocre jobs where he just has to
collect money from like little thugs and
he's like this is not me I need more
than this and just that ambition gets
the better of it how likely are we to
see you in the raid 3 I would know you
will have to ask the person who's doing
an interview right next to me he's the
director
he's the script writer director producer
and editor at the same time so he's a
yeah
and what isn't easy everything is that
Alpha and Omega how much would you like
to be in that C it would be wonderful
not just because of the raid itself but
because I really enjoy working together
with Gareth because he's not one of
those riders who are just like you need
to follow my script to the dot he's more
like you know if you have a good idea
Finn if you have a better idea let's
let's go with it
and there was this one particular scene
I can't tell you much about it at the
moment but basically we improvised half
the scene on the spot and the fun part
was we didn't tell the other actors
about it and we didn't tell the crew
about it so it was just our little
secret
and he said Finn you know what when I
give you the signal we use the new
material but before that just do use the
old material and then he gave me the
sign he's like Finn and then we use the
new material and we got the perfect
reaction from all the co-stars so what's
good it's nice I love it keep using the
secret hey now what can we look forward
to next review there is a movie in the
making I can't tell you about it yet
because nothing has been signed but it's
an action film again so cooking
Hollywood this time no not yet no sorry
look forward to lots more here and I'm
sure Hollywood will wake up to you very
soon
amen to that I'll keep him how keeping
my fingers crossed there
you